rumi the 13th century persian poet who
was born on the land that is now
afghanistan is there something in his
words that speaks to you about the
spirit of the afghan
people i mean everyone owns rumi i guess
i'd say i mean that's going to get me in
trouble with certain afghan fans of rumi
who
want to see him as as an afghan i would
say
are they proud of rome yeah did they see
him as an afghan do they yeah i mean so
it again it depends i mean some some
people
will be militant and say
you know the irony is going to have him
he's ours
um
but they're also saying you know he's
i mean you could say again he's like
rorschach blood i mean he's he's a sufi
he's a muslim
he's essential asian he's iranian he's
afghan
he's a turk i'm trying to get the
analogy but he's
he's something special to everyone so i
guess i would i would not walk into that
conversation and claim that he's one or
another but it's a cool thing i mean
it's the um
but i'm glad you brought that up because
that's a good way of seeing
[Music]
a seeing something that afghans i mean
we love our country afghanistan and say
okay roomies everyone you know madonna
helped make famous united states you
know for better for worse they used to
sell stuff at starbucks and that's all
complicated um
and embarrassing and his his
translations are very much disputed
where you have people being like there's
some awful roomy translations and there
are
they're also a lot of
speaking of the internet there are lots
of uh fake roomie quotes yes
you know like rumi said always be your
best
okay
we didn't say that you know that was you
know i mean this kind of stuff that but
yeah but now the cool thing is like the
um
i mean i think you can read rumi as a
religious thinker
but you can also you know
read rumi as a um
you know in an islamic sense but you
also read him as a kind of spiritualist
right as someone who or an ethicist or
moralist and so i think that's
i like the
the lens of roomie as a gateway to
afghan um ecumenicism and
cosmopolitanism you know the theme i
keep emphasizing of
of
meeting actual afghans who were actually
you know fluent in russian fluent german
fluent turkish
they know dari they know pashto
um
they've gone to university or sometimes
they haven't
and yet i mean they are um i like the
category of the uh
popular intellectual you know the
intellectual who isn't
isn't formally educated necessarily
although of course that's represented
too especially increasingly now this
generation of going university all over
the world you know stanford mit
everywhere
um africans are war reps into there
but just being
i don't have any kind of worldly
knowledge that is
not limited to a province to a village
to a hamlet but
sometimes it is but sometimes it's not
because of
again not because of some fairytale
story of
curiosity wandering the globe out of
you know some sense of of privilege but
out of necessity out of survival of
having to adapt and it's really um
extraordinary that i mean also let me
think about like professions so like
yeah ask ask afghan you know what does
he or she do for a living
and what have they done in the past i
mean the answer is one gets
shoe salesmen
tax cut drivers
uh surgeons all in one guy
yeah i mean that's i mean that's not
just afghan but that's you know that
that's very common but it's also russia
is the same that's right
whenever there's complexities to the
economic system and that's right a short
term and the long-term history of how
the country develops and it's basically
the people figuring out their way
around
a mess of a country politically yeah but
a uh beautiful flourishing culture and
humanity yeah and that that creates
super interesting people yeah yeah so we
can often see okay there's taliban
there's war there's
uh economic malfunction
there's harboring of terrorists there's
opium trade all that kind of stuff but
there's humans there with deep
intellectual
lies
uh and
like i love the movie love crimes and
the same kind of uh hopes fears and
desire to love
the the old romeo and juliet story and i
think roomy to me represents that
the wit
the intelligence but also the
just eloquent and just beautiful
representation of humanity of love some
of the
some of the best quotes about love are
from him half of them fake right
half of them real but the best ones are
real right the best ones are yeah yeah
the best ones are real uh robert this is
an incredible conversation thank you
very much thank you for the
tour of
afghanistan and making me making us
realize that um
there's much more to this country
than um what we may think
it's a it's a beautiful country and it's
full of beautiful people you made me
think about a lot of new things too so
it was definitely
definitely great on my own too so thank
you so much
you